I have the distinct privilege and honor
of introducing our speaker for this
evening Sam Brownback was sworn in as
ambassador-at-large for International
Religious Freedom on February 1st 2018
which means he's been on the job for a
little more than eight months I assume
that means he's got it all figured out
he previously served as governor of
Kansas from 2011 to 2018 prior to that
he served as a United States Senator and
he also served as a United States
representative from Kansas he has also
served as Kansas Secretary of
Agriculture and as was a White House
Fellow in the office of the US Trade
Representative he's a graduate of Kansas
State University in the University of
Kansas School of Law he and his wife
Mary have five children while a member
of the US Senate he spent a lot of his
time on the issue of religious freedom
in multiple countries around the world
he was a key sponsor of the
International Religious Freedom Act of
1998
prior to his public service he was a
private attorney in Kansas he taught
agricultural law Kansas State University
and he's a co-author of two books on the
subject one of them at least is titled
appropriately enough Kansas agricultural
law well I noticed the book slightly
jazzier subtitle is the state motto of
Kansas it's a Latin phrase odd astra per
aspera which translates as to the stars
through difficulties or through
adversities or through hardships and it
struck me when I saw this that this
motto is very similar to the motto of
Hillsdale College virtuse
tend to mean a Gaudet or as we say in
Hillsdale strength rejoices in the
challenge to put it another way these
two mottos are an essential agreement
the things that are truly worth having
or achieving in life
take a lot of hard work our speakers
many years of devoted public service
first to his home state of Kansas and
then to the nation are a testament to
his embrace of this fact we are grateful
for his service and for his presence
here tonight his topic is religious
liberty and economic liberty please
welcome to the podium ambassador Sam
Brownback
thank you to appreciate that very much
it's a pleasure to be here I'm a big fan
of Hillsdale College I've read different
publications over the years from
Hillsdale they have been fabulous you
hold to truth you fight you defend and
you produce great graduates - I've got
one in my office now Mallika willoughby
Mallika stand up here and take a
Hillsdale bow she is fabulous she
carries your banner high she argues from
principle and she argues which I really
appreciate because I think a lot of
times conservatives are people with
conservative principles too much of the
time we won't argue we're just kind of
you feel like the whole world is against
you and it's you against ten people in
the room and you know I don't know if I
want to argue on this right now and they
just don't alright well if you don't
argue you lose you don't get in the
fight you lose you got to get in the
fight you got to really get in there and
defend and I've found people from
Hillsdale they'll get in there and
defend so thank you for being in there
and being willing to stand up to the
challenge particularly in a culture
today that is awfully difficult to do
this in as we saw in the Cavanaugh
hearing this last week and and the vote
and I've been in public life a long time
and for the most of it people are really
quite civil I and you know they'll they
may not agree with you but they don't
come up to you at a restaurant and start
yelling or screaming at things usually
particularly in this part of the country
but boy it seems like that civility is
really leaving the public square and I
hope you'll continue to argue I hope
you'll continue to be civil about it as
well because the civility is really
needed in a democracy for it to be able
to function and just
and even if the other guys aren't
willing to be civil we should be civil I
know you just I that just should be a
basic it should be a foundational you
don't do it that way and honestly good
is this wonder gonna happen before long
every member of Congress is going to
have security details they're not gonna
be able to go out in public without
everybody coming through some metal
detector and a lot of things when I was
a representative representing people we
have a representative democracy I got a
lot of my input at ball games and soccer
matches in the grocery store and just
being out and you'd look at polling
numbers and data and everything all the
time but you don't you got to get the
human feel to it Abraham Lincoln would
call this taking a public opinion bath
when he would walk around you know I
just kind of kind of comes on yet what
you're gonna we're gonna lose that if
you lose the civility because people are
gonna be forced inside of fortresses
like they are in a lot of third-world
countries where the politicians aren't
out because it can't be it's not saved
we don't want that it's a terrible thing
to think and having left enough
commentary on that is I get fired up
about it
we we had a nice big win today that I've
got to really start off with even though
it's not right on point on the topic but
Andrew Brunson a pastor from North
Carolina was released
and as flying home maybe as we speak
even now on a aircraft coming back to
the United States he spent two years in
Turkish prison he was innocent he was
kept there by Turkey as I think a pawn
they wanted somebody released from here
who is here on asylum that there was no
grounds to send back and they just kept
well we want to trade this and then we
look we have a rule of law here if this
guy didn't do anything you can't ship
him out and they just kept him and then
it became a bigger deal and God bless
President Trump I and a lot of people
hit hammer at him all the time but her
Diwan the president of Turkey Trump kept
pushing him about you need to let this
guy go he is innocent we are not going
to trade this guy that you want for him
this guy needs to be let go he's
innocent
they kept Dodd laying this and that and
finally trumped I said okay if you're
not gonna do it I'm gonna put steel and
aluminum tariffs on your country and he
did it
it dropped their currency to record lows
by doing it and he said okay when you
guys are ready to let him go we'll we'll
talk about this I and they finally got
ready to let him go but you shouldn't
have to do this this is the first time
has ever done with a NATO ally on top of
it but God bless this president he's
won't fight that's why I was talking
with at the outset he's willing to fight
and that's why I'm delighted to be in a
position like this Tim mentioned the
places I've been it had the opportunity
to serve and it's been a great
opportunity and this is a wonderful
country we are at a tough time just in
the civil discourse and the philosophy
of the nation of how we're going to go
or move forward or not
and it's all the more important that
people like you do get in the fray and
you do know why you believe what you
believe
and you're willing to articulate from
that position of knowledge why you do
these things and you're willing to train
and teach people from that position and
so please really keep doing it I've got
a few comments that I want to make for
about 10-15 minutes and I'd be happy to
take questions and comments from people
after that I want to start from the
philosophical position because that's
the one that Hillsdale would start from
that is we believe in religious freedom
as a country it's in our first it's in
our Constitution it's in the First
Amendment the founding fathers deeply
believed in this right it was something
that's in our DNA it was a reason why a
number of people came to the United
States in the first place as they were
seeking religious freedom they were
seeking a place that they could
establish and build off of that base to
move forward I was in Salt Lake City
earlier this week meeting with the head
heads of the LDS Church and they went to
Utah seeking the same thing a place
where they could establish in their own
religious freedom and have that and have
that as a as a hallmark it is in our DNA
it is in this place we believe in
religious freedom but we believe in it
not as a government right we believe in
it as a god-given right this is a right
you have as being a dignified human
individual as a person you have this
right from the Creator not from
government we do not believe government
has a right to interfere with this right
the government's role is to protect the
right of religious freedom is to protect
your right to believe whatever you
choose or to change that belief or to
believe in nothing at all that is your
god-given right and government's role is
to protect that right against all comers
that you have this inherent right and
it's building you as a dignified human
individual that would be the Hillsdale
explanation of religious freedom from
our viewpoint it happens to also be in
our Constitution an absence also be in
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights that most countries around the
world sign 70 years ago and yet today in
the world 80% of the world's population
according to Pew lives in a religiously
restrictive atmosphere where they do not
have this right to choose as they would
choose they are restricted and then
after and I
been trying to figure out why is the
world this way today and the the best I
can come up with is when the Berlin Wall
came down people started moving all over
the world as did ideas start moving all
over the world and he started to clash
into each other at different places
prior to the Berlin Wall coming down
okay this is the Hindu region of the
world this is the Christian region of
the world this is the Muslim this is the
Buddhist this is the this this this kind
of everybody in your place but then
after that it just people started moving
and they started to have more
intersective ideas and then the
political class decided you know what
there's some value here if we favor the
majority religion over the minority
religion and saying you know let's let's
we're going to exclude the minority or
we're going to limit them or we're going
to try this or that and we'll subtle
raise ways or in or not so subtle ways
and you started getting a lot more
religious restrictions put on people as
this took place to the point now we have
eighty percent of the world having this
this administration believes this is a
foundational right that is important to
to assure that people around the world
have this and they're willing to fight
for this right
we had a ministerial earlier this year
ministerials were foreign ministers from
all over the world get together this was
the first one that's ever happened we
did it in July this year had 84
countries present and it was about
advancing religious freedom as a
fundamental right and it's a fundamental
right as I said that you inherently have
as an individual but we also believe it
has side benefits which are the reason
for this topic tonight is that we as we
look at it as we study it and look at it
this right if it is insured for an
individual does several other things as
well
one is you will have less terrorism if
you have more religious freedom and why
is that well you it's in the studies
that this has happened that way but also
just think about it for a couple of
minutes if you're told we will not let
you raise your children the way you want
to raise those children we're not gonna
let you let them go to church before
their age of 18 you cannot go to the
church before you cannot go into the
mosque before age of 18 of the children
we are not going to allow this or
there'll be a number of people that
would kind of go okay I guess I'll go
along but there will also be that group
of people that will say no I have a
right to educate my family and believe
the way I want to and to train my family
the way I want to see that and they will
fight you and we'll find that we find
that then and the data without religious
freedom there is more terrorism in those
countries there's a second piece of it
we find in the data that with less
religious freedom there's less economic
growth and economic opportunity and that
that religious freedom brings in and
we're not sure exactly why this is but
it brings in more thought and brings in
more diversity brings in more diversity
of talent into a place that there can be
more economic growth so it has a fruit
there as well and then there's a third
piece to it and this one's hard to
quantify but it's true and I hope we
started to get some economic data on
this when you have religious freedom it
releases a spiritual capital into a
country and spiritual capital I want to
define and describe as as that that
releasing of the the thousands the
millions of different civic groups that
have a religious bent to them that start
building schools and hospitals and
daycares and and doing all sorts of
different things to take care of the
people that are poor I was recently in
Uzbekistan we're working with that
country on religious freedom and I was
touring a couple of places of faith and
I'm leaving one of them and there's a
guy there that they introduced me to a
couple of guys that were there and they
were cleaning these grapes up and I
started talking with them and one of the
guys and he said well time your story
and he through the interpreter he said
look I was an alcoholic I couldn't get
back on my feet this church took me in I
now have a faith I am here I'm starting
to stabilize and lift up and I used that
example to the uzbek that I spoke to us
that this is what I mean about the
release of spiritual capital this guy is
on the street a drunkard without that
church but with it he's gotta live you
released the spiritual capital for the
this guy to be able to come forward and
that happens in millions of cases around
the world but if you're a religiously
restrictive country you limit that
spiritual capital from being released in
the nation and so we push that with
countries as well this next year we will
do another religious freedom summit of
Nations we'll invite people and civic
groups from all over the world to come
this last year we had over 500
individuals most representing different
civic groups or faith-based groups I
think will triple the size this next
year because there's just this inherent
there's an untapped group here there's a
there's a pent-up demand for this
there's no international body that deals
with religious disputes we have them on
trade we have them on military we have
them on on routes we have them on how
you divvy up space there's no
international body that deals with
religious disputes these kin religions
can be a very powerful force for good
they can also be things that end up
being used for ill and honestly we're
going to create an international body
and I don't think we should but we need
to create a dialogue we need governments
to look at this as saying the role of
government is to protect the right it's
not to pick a winner or loser in faith
that to see the inherent dignity of an
individual as they move forward so
that's what we are doing that's what
this administration is going to fight
for that's what we're gonna push as we
go along and unfortunately we've seen
many places around the world where this
is just not the case I want to give you
a couple of examples I've got another
thought I want to put out and then then
I'll close we see in China and we're
unfortunately seeing this and happened
in a very aggressive way now where for a
long period of time long period several
decades the Chinese were opening up more
and more to outside world there was this
really kind of this den shopping
philosophy of not being hardcore on the
communist ideology but more I take it as
really being centrally described
as his statement associated with him
that it doesn't matter whether a cat is
black or white it's whether it catches
mice so is this this nature of just
being well pragmatic and they were
opening up and allowing different
religions to operate Muslims and Falun
Gong and Buddhists and Christians it was
growing fast as a Christian nation and
by some numbers it was going to be the
largest Christian nation in the world in
20 years but that is all being shut down
pick up some of the recent international
stories of what's happening to the
Uighur population it's a Muslim
population in the western part of China
so you may have seen the cover stories
in Economist magazine or the New York
Times and other places got they say in
these stories up to a million people in
re-education camps because of them being
Muslims they've got a big data system
that it has Big Brother running it and
facial recognition cameras all over the
place and in major leaguer towns to
where they see an individual they see if
they walk into a mosque that ended
quickly it immediately identifies the
individual if you go in twice in a week
it limits other places that you're
allowed to go in this country this is
Big Brother using big data artificial
intelligence to subdue a population the
guy that runs this is the same guy that
that did basically cultural genocide
over Tibet and what he did with the
Buddhist population the Communist Party
Chairman over Tibet was moved to the
Muslim region of the world we're looking
at this and I'm looking at and to me
it's one of the most if not the most
concerning religious freedom situation
in the world
because it's the future if the Chinese
perfect this system what will keep them
from selling it to other authoritarian
regimes in different places around the
world and say you want to we want to put
down a restive population we got the
system for you and it sounds eerily like
some of the futuristic books that people
would talk about on having these sort of
big data police states that you can read
about it's to me it's deeply concerning
we see this situation in Iran today if
you are of the minority faith
you get run out you can get executed the
regime executed at least 20 individuals
for one thing last year their religious
beliefs and how they practice them if
your Baha'i the persecution is
relentless if you're of the wrong
Islamic faith the persecution continues
and I can take you to different regions
of the world Burma the Rohingya
population is dominantly Muslim being
run out by dominantly Buddhists in the
country not the only factor but yet a
main one what we want to see happen is
instead of more persecution more
discrimination and more restrictions we
firmly believe that the gates of
religious freedom should fly open around
the world that the iron curtain
withholding religious freedom should
come down so that people are free to
exercise this right that most nations
have actually agreed to but few actually
practice it's in our founding it's in
our future and we believe it'll be
something of great help I just don't
want to close with a recognition of what
Hillsdale College to me means in this
country and I've had the great honor to
be a public servant in this nation for a
number of years you've been one of the
real bellwethers you've been one of the
real philosophical trainers and I look
around the room and yeah I think if
you're gonna be the philosophical
trainer for one of the major
philosophies governing philosophies in
this country of 320 million people or
what or whatever we are shouldn't this
room be at least double the size
shouldn't it be much bigger but yet I
find in most movements in the United
States most serious movements the core
of it's relatively small but it's its
philosophical it believes in it it's
willing to fight you're the Marines of
the philosophy I've got a son that's a
marine that doesn't give me the right to
say it but I did
I love your motto pursue truth defend
Liberty as as key ones and you've done
that and keep doing it please in this
time of such difficulty and division in
this nation we need you out there we
need you to be happy about it too
I on the other side can be dour and mean
I want to be a happy warrior I want to
be out there fighting because I believe
in this principle and I'm happy I'm in
the fight I could be out doing so I can
be out selling shoes and instead I get
to be a warrior and a big fight that's
important for a lot of people around the
world and you are - you're in this fight
and it and if America doesn't stand for
these principles nobody else around the
world will nobody else will fight for
them so that makes it all the much more
of a big burden on us to defend these
things and they work they work this is a
complete aside but as governor of Kansas
I signed nineteen pro-life bills because
I believe that a person it's that a
young human is a person and not a piece
of property and it is
and you say okay will you sign nineteen
pro-life bills yeah there were 17,000
fewer abortions during that six year
time period that I was governor there
are people alive today because of that
philosophy they're people alive today
because of the philosophical truths you
push that are actually alive actually
alive
you got a fight you got a push forward
pray for this nation pray for our future
pray for this president pray for air I
pray for every president I prayed for
Barack Obama almost every night even
though I disagreed with him vehement ly
but I hope you do and and stand there on
those god-given principles that are that
have made this nation have made this
world and wherever they have operated in
this world they have made those nations
great and you're starting to see some
countries return back to I was just in
Poland moving back towards those
philosophies and I and not that they
don't have some problems final thought
and I will open to ask questions I met
recently with a guy with Oxford
analytical and some of you'll be
familiar with their materials that they
put out they put out real high-quality
thoughts and an analysis on key problems
and questions of the day and I was
asking him I said you know one thing
that I would ask you to think about is
what you also put in your analysis when
you do in certain areas and maybe it
doesn't apply to all fields would you
put in there a spiritual analysis to the
problem would you put in there a thought
about okay what's the spiritual nature
of this problem and what's the answer
and get your great thinkers that you
bring together from around the world and
to address this I was in a meeting I
want to give you an example this two
days ago I was in a meeting with a
series of other ambassadors from Europe
and they were talking about the the
problems in this country and where this
group of people is treated wrong because
there was a problem that happened 50
years ago these people were killed by
that group of people and the the the
problem keeps being re-energized and
brought back up in the
latest generation I said well why don't
we ever deal with the root of the
problem I pointed out that in when I was
governor of Kansas when I was in the US
Senate I carried a bill in the Senate
and got passed into law to apologize for
broken treaties that we had with Native
Americans to acknowledge that we broke
some of these treaties and we were
specific with it and and said and we
shouldn't have this was wrong they say
okay well why'd you do that well because
if you look at what you know where's my
specific example of it is western Kansas
we've got an aquifer under western
Kansas it's called the Ogallala Aquifer
we've been overusing it for years and
they're about to drain it for being able
to agricultural use and you go out and
you talk with farmers
why are you overusing it well because
I'm going to use all the water I can and
then when it's all done I'll just move
to dryland farming and take the profits
I took from irrigation and buy more
dryland farming and that's my analysis
you know what that's so short-sighted
for the future and for your kids and
your grandkids yeah but it's the way we
got to go well what was really happening
it was you had a sin agreed over the
land sin follows the land is what it
says biblically so until you deal with
that well where did the greed come from
well we'd stolen the land weed off of
the Native Americans we hadn't dealt
fairly with them until we went and
apologized and we did and a group of
great Christian people with a number of
Native Americans and they went through a
series of ceremonies and apologies and
acknowledging this taking place and to
where number of the Native American
leaders are sent okay it's dealt with
we're done now you can go out there and
you can find farmers aggressively
pursuing sustainable use of the water
saying I want to preserve this for
future generations we can cut this back
down because the greed the sin of greed
that have followed the land has been
lifted it's been dealt with and there
are people that don't have a box for
that sort of discussion and I've respect
that but why do the problems keep coming
and keep going on and we never saw them
maybe we should think
about things this way from time to time
maybe our founders thought of things
this way because you know they did these
these were people that looked at the
grid this way and yet we as a society we
got no I've got this great mind I got
this great computer we'll just fix it
that way and the problems don't get
fixed we don't ever go back to the
basics we've got it you gotta deal with
it the way God set the problem up we got
to do it thank you god bless you all
let me attempt to take comments
questions I guess for I don't know how
you guys do it but they told me to take
questions and I'm happy to happy to try
and I have found my favorite tide a lot
of people ask me well would you like
being a senator or governor better this
or that I've got my favorite title
grandpa I've got three grandchildren I'm
expecting a fourth and those are awesome
thank you again for your service to our
country and for your talk this evening
my question has to do with where does
religion and responsibility intersect
now as you know for years we have been
more on a Christian biblical standard
where do we get our standards if
everyone is allowed to do what is right
in his own eyes or his own religion one
of the reasons why we say that taking
land from the Indians was wrong because
we had promised and we violated our word
keeping your word is one of the big
problems we have in our society today
that's one of the reasons we have so
much debt you know if people would think
more about the importance of keeping
their word they would be less likely to
borrow and I dare say our nation the
same thing so the Bible speaks strongly
about that we are made in God's image
and God never breaks his word so again
the point I'm making here is it's nice
to say freedom of religion but you got
to be careful because otherwise there
everybody is allowed to do what he
thinks his religion allows and he'll say
whatever he's of a religious nature
whatever satisfies his own does
so I'd like you to comment on that where
do we get our standards of right and
wrong and is there a history in our
nation about one religion being dominant
in terms of those standards thank you
yeah I get it that one well let me let
me just do it this way the remember the
founders they were they provided a huge
amount of freedom they believed in
freedom and liberty it's a big piece of
what they saw here and they saw they saw
a limited government with its role being
specific specific specified and a broad
right for the individual and then the
individual would do self-governance that
would be and they would talk often about
the need for faith or religion within
the individual because the government's
role was limited and I believe they did
this off the design of the way God
created us God created us with this
Liberty this incredible freedom and he
had to know when he did it that we would
mess it up and then he'd have to clean
it up then and did so but there must be
something powerful in the notion of
freedom and liberty must be something
incredibly powerful in that that God
would would would invest in us something
that he would have to pay so much to
clean up but it was still so powerful
well that's what I see ours is on
freedom of religion and that's why I
think they built it in the Constitution
the way they did is that you have this
freedom and it is yours and it's yours
from God these rights come from God they
don't come from us and but our role is
to protect the right but then we hope
that there'll be lots of people out in
the society that will have the
self-governance within them because
that's the way the system was founded
that's the way it was as I look and see
that it was designed so you know you can
say alright well how are you doing on
that today okay god we got difficulties
I still don't want to move away from the
design
maybe then we should have more people
saying well then I need to get much more
serious about my faith I need to be out
there in the public square with it
that's the way I'd try to answer it very
much for your service in behalf of
religious freedom my question is what
tool in the American foreign policy
PlayBook do you think is not being used
enough to help China respect the
religious freedom of its own citizens
we're in a trade dispute with China now
I don't think that's news to anybody
here we I'm a free trader and I think we
should have engaged the Chinese on trade
dispute a decade ago they've been
working the system they've been stealing
intellectual property they've been
mercantilist in currency and I think we
I think we should have been fighting
with him a long time ago it's one of the
reasons I'm such a fan of this president
the guy will act he'll do something this
is a complete sidebar but this group
would appreciate this I tried four dozen
years to get our embassy moved to
Jerusalem and everybody would say no
it's gonna blow the world up there'll be
all this fighting it'll take a place I
said no you have a weekend of protest
and it'll be over President Trump comes
in boom just do it
move the embassy it's moved there was a
weekend a protest and it's there you
know that's
so I love about this guy I I think in
and and here's this is sam brownback
thought okay so this isn't
administration policy and but i think
there'd be general agreement within the
administration the chinese government is
holding itself up now is saying we have
a legitimate system that other
governments should follow around the
world you don't have to follow this
free-market democracy system that
everybody's saying yeah you got to go
free-market democracy free-market device
no you don't have to you can be a
one-party rule mercantilist lack of
human rights and this is a legitimate
global system that other countries
should follow and consider for their own
path because it may fit them this is the
china third way or other way i think we
ought to be pointing out in particular
the lack of human rights under that
model the lack of human rights the lack
of the dignity of the individual under
that model i think we ought to be
pressing them hard that say okay this is
your model how does that apply if you
decide to be a person of faith and you
want to have that religious freedom what
do you get to have and i i think it's
one of the very strengths of our
argument is to argue on the basis of
human rights and i I think that's
something we and you're seeing this come
forward the vice president gave a speech
last week on China noting this the the
situation's getting much clearer I think
and I hope we continue to emphasize
those we had a debate here at this table
friendly discussion about how Reagan
used human rights you think about it he
advocated for the Soviet Jews to be able
to leave and the evangelicals be able to
leave out of the Soviet Union he goes to
Gorbachev he goes to the Berlin wall
that was on their ton to their country
in their territory and what's he point
out he points out that the wall was
built there to keep people in not to
keep people out
that's why why do you build a wall to
keep people in well because you got a
horrible system that people
love to get out of they got a human
right and then he says and those
powerful words that created so much mr.
Gorbachev bring down this wall
he didn't have a tank or a dozer
anywhere when had tanks around he'd have
any dozers anywhere around to move that
that wall came down that day and he gave
people hope and that's why you use human
rights I can take you to people that
have been in jail for ten years I can
take you to North Korean individuals
that when the United States starts
talking about human rights for North
Koreans they heard it they were in a
little village in rural area in North
Korea and it gave them hope and they
started fighting because they started
agitating more because somebody actually
heard their plight and it's a strength
of who we are I could you could if you
would meet with some of the people that
I meet with and hear how the Yazidis
were treated by Isis in northern Iraq
this is a religious minority a tiny
religious philosophy that they they
center around this one mountain Sinjar
mountain but the ISIS people said these
are demon worshippers therefore they
deserve to die a horrible death
the women deserve to be trafficked I met
with women that were trafficked they
were sold seven ten times I met with a
woman who had a fifteen-year-old
mentally [ __ ] child beat out of her
hands taken from her and her sold seven
times and you know why well because this
person thinks you've got a bad religion
and that entitled them in their thought
and philosophy to take this
fifteen-year-old mentally [ __ ] child
out of your hands that's wrong
with the recent release of Andrew
Brunson was that something your office
was directly involved in and could you
give us some more information about that
yes who were but but we were involved
the president did this the president got
this done he raised it often with the
president turkey of erdowan he raised it
insistently
and when herded one wouldn't respond he
slapped him with tariffs I've not seen
another president that would have done
that so yes we advocated and and raised
it consistently in every place we
possibly could the president got this
done
[Applause]
hey hey thanks yes thank you
they've got a microphone there they're
good thank you in the position that you
have now is it possible that you can
work at all to put God back in our
schools not from this position the the
the bill that created this position this
was created by Congress and and pushed
and we specifically excluded domestic
religious freedom issues from it because
even then 20 years ago these were
starting to really divide the the
population and I'd say so we wouldn't
have had much of any Democrats support
for the bill at that time it was and it
was primarily religious conservatives
that were pushing the bill because we're
just seeing all this religious
persecution really gaining strength
around the world but we specifically
include excluded domestic religious
freedom issues which are basically
starting to to divide into one of two
camps the the limiting camp wants us to
be freedom of worship so you're free to
do whatever you want to in your house of
worship but not outside of it and the
other looks at it as a freedom of
religion which means you're a person and
you've decided that you have a faith and
you're free to take that faith wherever
you go in public and express and be that
as long as it doesn't harm another
individual you know first far is that
you you can't punch another individual
because my faith says you can you can't
you can't do that but otherwise you're
free to take that so it's really that
decision about freedom of worship very
limiting of this right to freedom of
religion very expansive right and now
you've the supreme court's taking these
cases up they've taken a couple of cases
up and they'll I'm sure they're going to
take more up because this is really one
of those foundational issues that the
society and the culture that needs
decisions on and so I this last election
cycle was so important about that you
had two judges on the Supreme Court that
are going to
deeply involved and remembered for me
and as conservatives we believe you know
these basic rights are very broad-based
even if even if you don't like some of
it you know like the First Amendment
I don't like pornography but you know
you I believe in a very expansive Bill
of Rights you know when you just okay
then that's what we stand for cuz that's
philosophically we believe I believe it
if the First Amendment's an expansive
right so is the Second Amendment it's
not a limiting right you know you got to
have a consistency in your your
definitions what you're going to see
these these rights be significantly
taken up by the court and continue to
because it's just such a such a big
issue in the society we take one one
question more and and I'll let you let
you roll there's a guy back here okay
Thank You ambassador uh I just had a
question because you've talked a number
of times about expanding religious
freedom but what what about where you
have particular traditions or faith
systems that are completely incompatible
with existence for other systems like
for instance Isis trying to bring back
the medieval Caliphate or in London for
instance the ever-expanding religious
freedom led to the establishment of a
judge system in Sharia law in certain
areas that led to the oppression of
their own people so you have an
expanding religious freedom and at the
same time certain incompatible systems
that oppress their own people so how do
you negotiate those things yeah one as I
mentioned that you can't use your
religious freedom right to punch
somebody else or it kills somebody else
that that is a clear limitation on it
and that and that should be there I'm
going to point out and you we've got a
big debate going on these in this
country while I was governor of Kansas I
signed a bill that said the Constitution
the United States is the law of the land
for the state of Kansas and we don't
recognize any other laws that come in to
the state that are not based on the
constitution the united states
constitution again
well people and we had people are
protesting about well this was just
designed to limit Sharia law from coming
into Kansas and I said no this is about
defending the Constitution because
that's where our rights that we have
limited as a country set up as a country
is in this set of Rights and it it
limits any other piece that comes in
because ours is built on this
Constitution where a rule of law nation
what I think that would apply to the
same same situation there that this our
law is based on the Constitution that
Constitution has its philosophical basis
and I think that's where that's where
those are that's the way that I would
handle and look at at those those sets
of issues again thank you you've been
very kind to to let me speak to you of a
group that I've admired so long stay in
this fight if you're a supporter of this
group help them out if you're a teacher
don't ever lose your philosophical basis
and thank you for being well if you're a
college university or campus teacher
thank you for standing up for basic
rights and and another philosophy that
maybe the least that less dominant on
your campus it seems like your campuses
are all dominated and hard on the left
anymore and if you're if you're standing
up there thank you for getting that
diversity of thought out there which I
always thought universities are supposed
to be all about but anymore it seems
like we're just getting so much more
narrow on what we allow to be taught and
and then the the route forward for so
many people is to not allow a debate as
to shout you down that if you have a
different philosophy you're not entitled
to speak well that's wrong that's not
the way this country operates and keep
speaking keep standing up and you're
probably going to get bricks thrown at
you and lots of difficulties but keep
standing up one final story I want to
share with you now because I think this
really describes where I feel like a lot
of philosophical conservatives are
anymore mother Teresa was going door to
door before she was a well-known figure
in India
and she was collecting money because she
needed it for her orphanage and for home
for the dying and so she's going
door-to-door to try to get money in
Calcutta which I can't imagine she
raised much money that way but she was
hard up I guess and said she was doing
that she goes and knocks on this one
guy's door and a friend of mine saw this
happen she knocks on the door and she's
asking for money and the guy saw her saw
her habit that she had on he spit in her
face because he didn't didn't believe in
her and what she did and spit in her
face she took it wipe the spit off and
she said okay that's for me yeah I
accepted I need some money for the
children and he gave her some money and
I always thought you know of sorts
that's what it can be like at times you
feel like you're standing up he just
gets bit in the face for everybody here
saying look Wade I know this is the
right thing this is truth I'm standing
for truth I'm defending truth why am I
getting spit on what may not be for you
maybe that's for your humility it's
actually for the kids it's for the next
generation it's for the people that
follow us and if we don't stand nobody
will so take it as a humbling thing that
happens to you
there's no humility without humiliation
a friend of mine once said I don't know
if I like that or not but humility is a
good thing keep standing
[Applause]